bonsoir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs de retour
pour une nouvelle saison bonsoir et loi
bonsoir
stéphane bonsoir à tous donc on était
chargé notamment avec ce fameux
championnat de france de vichy qu'on a
retransmis en direct
oui allons effectivement donc toutes les
émissions sont archivés on ne le redira
jamais assez donc vous pouvez revoir
toutes les anciennes émissions qu'on a
fait à vichy qui sont d'excellente
facture avec des parties commentées par
etienne bacrot par iossif donc man par
les meilleurs joueurs du tournoi
tout est archivé et en plus ça a été
taguée c'est à dire que quand vous allez
sur une émission vous pouvez aller
directement à ce qui vous intéresse tout
est segmenté et c'est donc très simple
d'accès donc archives de diagonale avec
la nouvelle présentation des gones à la
représentation de l'été présentation de
l'été tout à fait tu parles du générique
ou non non je ne parle pas du nouveau
générique c'est bon que vous avez pu
apercevoir ici ah oui il est vraiment à
sion en location internet internet
d'accord vous permet donc d'accéder à
toutes les émissions à tout bouquet
diagonale de façon simplifiée
oui on vous rappelle qu'il ya des gones
à la leçon vous invite à la suivre
puisque fait des leçons accessible du
débutant notamment joueurs confirmés et
il ya déjà une dizaine d'heures août est
néanmoins la dizaine d'émissions en tout
cas enregistrés où il s'agirait plutôt
d'une vingtaine d'émissions une
vingtaine d'émissions voilà donc une
dizaine d'heures voilà une dizaine
d'heures donc on va passer tout de suite
à l'actualité de la semaine avec
kasparov les zones a et c
l'actualité de la semaine
voilà donc ces événements se sont donc
le tournoi zonal qualificatif
championnat du monde et on va d'abord
parlé de garry kasparov à paris puisque
on a rencontré le champion du monde
enfin en tout cas le meilleur joueur du
monde parce qu'on sait plus trop s'il
faut l'appeler champion du monde ou pas
à paris au sénat encore une fois le
sénat qui est loi fédère un petit peu
les échecs depuis quelques mois oui le
scénar rappelons le ils ont installé des
échiquiers pour les joueurs qui
fréquentent le jardin du luxembourg qui
est donc la propriété du sénat les
joueurs d'échecs sont bien venus là bas
donc ils ont installé de nouvelles
tables en lave émaillée donc une matière
très sénatoriales ça c'est pour le
jardin et pour le jardin également ils
ont participé en tant que partenaire
enfin en tant qu'organisateur
partenaires au grand prix du sénat vous
pouvez revoir les archers du grand prix
du sénat canal web gagné par shirov
gagné par shirov d'avant spassky très
intéressant au revoir donc effectivement
les matchs sont à revoir
et maintenant c'est un accueil garry
kasparov pour la projection du
documentaire en fait qui concerne toute
sa vie voilà donc il s'agit d'un
documentaire qui a été filmé et produit
par en partie par la 3 la scène qu'une
entreprise privée de vidéos françois et
arte orthez voilà ouverte et est donc et
ils ont suivi kasparov on nous avait
rencontré d'ailleurs quand on a fait le
reportage en hollande avec hands et ils
ont suivi des sports pendant presqu'une
année et donc ils ont ramené des images
des interviews des joueurs de kasparov
évidemment lui-même et ils ont suivi
chez lui
on vous en parlait aussi à sa famille à
son entourage donc c'est un film très
intéressante d'une heure que donc ils
ont présenté en avant-première au sénat
donc on y est et on a pu avoir le
plaisir de voir ce film qui va être
diffusée je crois la première fois le 7
octobre et la deuxième fois le 7
novembre
donc moi après donc juste en avant et
après le championnat qui doit faire
rencontrer kasparov contre cramique
allons le fameux match qu'elles soient
aux chroniques
effectivement ça sera en deuxième partie
de soirée donc le 7 octobre à 22h50 sur
france 3 donc ce reportage est bien
assez exceptionnelle puisqu'on va
kasparov dans des situations on n'a pas
forcément l'habitude de le voir
notamment quand il fait du sport par
exemple dans un filet d'espoir et
notamment torse nu torse nu donc très
peu souvent torse nu oui effectivement
mais en tout cas ce film est très très
intéressant en tout cas on voit la
personnalité réelle de garry kasparov
qui est vraiment un homme d'exception
qui a beaucoup d'idées assez qui est
pratiquement borné qui se tient vraiment
à ses idées on le voit avec son manager
ou et williams on le voit en famille on
le voit faire du merchandising enfin en
tout cas tenté de faire des produits
dérivés garry kasparov traiterait en
tout cas c'est très intéressant il ya
beaucoup de séquences assez amusante
c'est bien fait et on revoit des images
2d kenzy qu'on a pu vous présenter lors
du reportage qu'on avait fait donc en
janvier dernier voilà alors on va passer
tout de suite on va pas attendre plus
longtemps cette interview de garry
kasparov un peu plus ferme pour keanu
telle association est content
mais nivet inc à 8,6 me to
preneur de son et qui l'ont suivi donc
là voilà ça va à peu près mieux l'équipe
est très bonne mais
effectivement c'est difficile de
retracer sa vie intensive en tout cas en
tout cas de retracer la vie intensif de
garry kasparov à l'âge de 37 ans comme
il d'audi mais si elles n'étaient que
garry kasparov parle de lui-même à la
troisième personne
c'est intéressant c'était une remarque
assez intéressante là on a quelques
ennuis de son message à se résoudre en
tout cas pour conclure sur ce film garry
kasparov a parlé d'un bon projet d'une
bonne équipe et d'un gros travail à une
bonne coordination entre entre tous les
acteurs
alors deuxième sujet évidemment c'est le
match contre kramnik parce que c'est
vraiment l'actualité au moins deux
d'octobre ça démarre donc à londres il a
l'air très confiant très confiant et
dick en tout cas c'est un match qu'ils
estiment plus sérieux que ceux qui
étaient prévus contre chir en fait un an
oui alors bon garry kasparov est un peu
une double casquette dans ce match
effectivement puisque il est en même
temps organisateurs puisque c'est lui
qui cherche un job c'est lui qui le
choisit et en même temps joueurs donc là
se pose un gros dilemme pour garry
kasparov c'est de dire avec son
assurance habituelle je vais l'écraser
je vais le pulvériser ce qu'il dit
habituellement tant que joueur ce qu'il
pense toujours
ils se voient toujours favori et en tant
qu'organisateur c'est pas une très bonne
tactique de dire quelque chose comme ça
si ça dénature et un peu le match mais
en tout cas garry kasparov ici nous dit
que c'est un adversaire qui est plus
sérieux en tout cas que shiro foucault
ou même à nantes et qu' il le prend très
sérieusement à la façon dont ils
abordaient ce match entre karpov dans
les années 80 donc le match de 85
indiscutablement à ce match là bas il
dit qu'il va devoir combiner toute son
énergie pour essayer de battre amis on
va voir parce que bon on n'est toujours
pas de confirmation sur sur la venue de
ce match oui lancé le grand débat qui
nous qui nous tracasse tous mais enfin
en tout cas espérons que tout se passera
comme prévu que qu'il y aura un beau
match avec des belles parties des jolis
coups et de toute façon nous suivons ça
de très près d'angers gonal évidemment
alors l'autre actualité qui nous
intéresse alors je crois que avant tout
parce que ça c'est l'autre championnat
du monde celui un peu plus officiel tout
cas organisé par la fédération
internationale le tournoi zonal ce qu'on
appelle tour national si le tournoi de
qualification aux championnats du monde
on avait déjà parlé précédemment
christian bauer avait gagné le tournoi
précédent
c'est le seul français d'ailleurs assez
de qualifier or cette année on a
beaucoup de français qui sont au journal
puisqu'ils sont
7,7 et ils sont très très bien placé
alors ils sont surtout c'est une
nouvelle génération de joueurs français
il ya beaucoup de jeunes de jeunes très
prometteurs notamment le célèbre laurent
frayssinet donc qui qui joue là-bas ya
joël lautier bien sûr il ya nocives
dorfman les stars sont venues il n'ya
pas etienne bacrot puisqu'il est
directement qualifié pour l'étape
supérieure quel championnat du monde
lui-même en lui-même
donc il y aura lieu à new delhi et
teyran rappelons le toujours donc nos
français cartonne comme des fous puisque
après la sixième ronde
ils avaient tous plus que la moyenne oui
ce qui est quand même assez exceptionnel
quand on voit l'opposition qu'il ya en
face c'est à dire des joueurs comme
spielmann miles tibia cov rider manon
qui fait un très bon tournoi aussi
linderman qui n'est pas attendue et qui
n'est pas attendue gagne surprise
surprise ya vingt-deux velits pic est
surtout les hollandais qu'on attendait
très fort or là aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
22 lycées pris une claque qu'on peut
dire par jean-marc degraeve et les
français vraiment et sont en train de
démolir les adversaires c'est à dire que
la sur les huit premières tables il y
avait sept joueurs français aujourd'hui
c'est tout à fait exceptionnel
on n'a jamais vu ça en france il faut
bien le dire c'est historique
oui c'est une des premières fois où il
ya un espoir qu'il y ait au moins trois
quatre voire même cinq français qu'ils
aillent aux championnats du monde
puisqu'on en a déjà deux qui sont
qualifiés d'office c'est etienne bacrot
et boris parce que là c'est du jamais vu
c'est du jamais vu en espérant qu'il
vont durer jusque qui vont continuer
comme ça jusqu'au bout on a l'impression
que d'avoir fait le championnat de
france juste avant ça leur a donné une
espèce de peps supplémentaires donc faut
rappeler que donc lautier hochart nataf
même qui avait fait un bon début vont
bien peu chuté sur la feinte après
commencé avec trois et demi sur quatre
il se retrouve avec trois et demi sur
cette voie là donc il a il est un peu
perdue après mes frais signer bon mais
malgré sa défaite contre losier en fait
la seule défaite c'est contre nature
français non ça c'est dommage que les
français jouent ensemble
on ne peut pas faire autrement dorfman
qui pour l'instant de faire un tournoi
tranquille mais mais comme on a
l'habitude de le voir quand même
beaucoup de nuls mais ils gagnent quand
il faut d'hoffmann on sait qu'il est
capable
d'appuyer sur l'accélérateur à n'importe
quel moment c'est quand même un joueur
qui est capable de battre n'importe qui
malheureusement des fois ils s'arrêtent
en cours de route comme dans sa partie
contre etienne bacrot où il nous a
expliqué tout satisfait de terminer
deuxième du tournoi
ce que je voulais prouver dans cette
partie c'est pas que j'allais battre
etienne c'est que je pouvais le battre
c'est à dire que je pouvais jouer pour
le gain et une fois qu'il a obtenue une
position avec des belles perspectives
mal à proposer nul donc iossif toujours
surprenant mais en tout cas il est
capable de battre les meilleurs joueurs
du monde
il a un palmarès élogieux je viens de le
revoir cet après midi donc
rappelons le et ex entraîneur de
kasparov de 84 à 81 7 champion de russie
enfin le champion du rss 1977 champion
d'europe
alors ça je ne le savais pas été
champion d'europe en 1977 donc grande
année pour iossif est effectivement donc
méchant que je vois un joueur s'y
impliquant des champions de france 98 98
alors il faut noter que les joueurs qui
pourraient sans marche bien dans ce
journal c'est speedman marche bien rhein
d'hermann aussi qui malgré sa défaite
contre lautier continue à tenir le haut
du pavé à la gaude enock et surprend
c'est le champion italien godina on peut
parler un petit peu c'est donc ses
deuxièmes places et via une spécialité
c'est le sexe note c'est d'ailleurs la
fameuse crise d'autant godina
extrêmement régulièrement se retrouve
avec moins d'une minute pour jouer ces
vingt derniers coups et ça lui joue
souvent des tours alors en tout cas ici
j'ai l'impression qu'il ne souffre pas
trop de ce problème là donc affaire à
suivre s'il arrive à tenir jusqu'au bout
il est capable de faire des très grosses
parties voilà en tout cas c'est une demi
surprise et puis alors il ya francisco
vallier rose ou pack aux rôles et de
prononciation sont bonnes valero c'est
l'espoir espagnol qui est un peu
l'équivalent de notre peut-être
freyssinet en manière peut-être pas
macro parce que bakou un peu au dessus
mais il est un peu l'équivalent de notre
freyssinet nationale donc il fait bon
parcours aussi d'ailleurs on fait nul
ensemble oui tout à fait valero il a
fait une excellente performance la pompe
lounes en 99
donc le pont clown c'est le tournoi qui
est toujours en fin d'année je crois que
c'était l'année 98 99 ou quelque chose
comme ça il avait fait une performance
tout à fait remarquables dans cetet
99-2000 bien entendu où il avait je
crois fait le score de 6 7 me sur 9 dans
un tournoi qui regroupait joël thibaud
risque elles fondent
alexander morozevich et tous les
meilleurs joueurs du monde il avait
vraiment été surprenant à cette occasion
là et maintenant il fait il joue un bon
niveau de 2550 à peu près voilà donc la
surprise c'est que les favoris donc 22
hippique est qu'on pouvait attendre mais
sans on peut également auction je crois
aussi qu'ils soient un peu dans le mois
oui dans le mou dans le mou du tableau
voilà mais rien n'est fini puisqu'il
reste encore cinq parties après la
sixième ronde
c'est quand même serré mais les français
sont vraiment dans la première moitié du
tableau
tous les espoirs sont permis pour avoir
qu'on espère pourquoi pas trois
qualifiés français il ya que six places
qualificatives à ce championnat
frappé par contre je sais pas si elle et
des partages en cas d'égalité à louis
alors l'année dernière ce qui s'était
passé
c'était il y avait eu sept ex-aequo et
cinq places qualificatives
ça dépend de la force du groupe est une
idée qu'il ya eu donc un départage à 7
et en fait on tient compte du départage
du tournoi c'est à dire le but kohl's et
le système de départage d'un open en cas
de nouvelle égalité dans les listes des
partages d'accord bon on verra on voit
dans ces trois cas il peut y avoir des
il peut y avoir des souvenirs alors
l'apprend série en oublie le site est
quand même c'est que joël lautier de
dominos toi clairement voilà donc il
était premier tout seul hier aujourd'hui
la fait nul donc il reste premier au
moins ex-aequo je le tiens d'ailleurs
qui va faire le thème de la partie la
partie de la semaine
voilà partie de la semaine voilà
exactement où bonne transition tout de
suite avec la partie loti freyssinet
partie de la semaine
voilà donc tournoi zonal qualificatif au
championnat du monde donc très important
et pour la première fois les français se
débrouillent très bien et de cette
partie leproux puisqu'il pour rencontrer
joël lautier qui était en tête du tour
il fallait être aussi en tête et
freyssinet des en-têtes ils jouent donc
avec les noirs contre joué lautier
numéro un français depuis maintenant des
années on le connais bien c'est toujours
un des plus grands joueurs du monde il
est sien le le seul où un des rares en
tout cas joueur au monde à être positifs
canton kasparov n'aura peut-être pas
assez
c'est peut-être pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il
a participé on peut le dire à la
préparation de kramnik on sait qu'il est
parti voir chronique en russie pendant
pendant cet été donc qui reviennent tous
frais de sa préparation contre cramique
on peut supposer aussi qu'il n'a pas le
droit avant que crysis 2 100 matchs de
sortir ce qu'ils ont préparé avec lui
oui c'est clair c'est que rien c'est on
voit un jeu lautier qui ne jouent pas du
tout le répertoire de crédit puisque
dans ce tournoi ils jouent eux 4 alors
que chronique joue exclusivement le coup
un des quatre donc a priori ils ont
décidé de faire la part des choses c'est
à dire qu'ils travaillent ensemble
mais joël lautier ne reprend pas les
idées qu'ils ont travaillé en fait
contre kasparov
évidemment ça serait dommage d'utiliser
une semaine de travail entière et de la
dilapider dans une partie je dirais
entre guillemets contre freyssinet oui
puisque si c'est une préparation qui est
destiné à battre kasparov
évidemment ça marquera probablement un
point contre fasciné mais ce n'est pas
le but donc alors maintenant on va
peut-être passer en petit en bas à
droite de l'écran
voilà et nous allons commencer à voir
cette partie de la semaine donc partie
des enseignants que quatre noms qu a
donc joué là plutôt l'habitude de jouer
des quatre jeux lautier joue
principalement c4 il a des très bons
résultats avec l'anglais en deuxième
coup il choisit des quatre et on
dernière dernière arme il choisit le
coup eux quatre bons mais effectivement
de toute façon à ce niveau de la
compétition les joueurs ont tous la
possibilité de jouer toutes les
ouvertures pratiquement 4 et laurent
frayssinet succès 5 il a joué scandinave
très longtemps la scandinave c'est le
coût 17 des 5
on va remplir a ajouté que réputés un
peu douteux effectivement de toute façon
est servi sur des rails correct en
allant jouer une ouverture classique qui
la défense ménages de l'ofs
donc ça laisse trois des six en a déjà
commandé sept 7 ouvertures dans les
émissions précédentes donc d4 on ouvre
le centre pour lui blanc échanges au
centre cavale et prend des quatre
cavaliers fz6 attaque l'option central e
4 il faut protéger la santé c'est encore
une fois ci c'est d'écologie consorts
lecavalier en même temps on crée une
attaque sur le pion central les blancs
réplique par cas laissée trois coups
logique on sort le cavalière des comptes
défend le pion hélas le coup qui tient à
terry zl1 snh deroff si ce coût à 7 à 6
donc ici qui est très prophylactique
puisque en fait l'idée de ce coup c'est
que ça a un coût et il contrôle la
classe b 5 et le fou j'ai le fou s'est
vite contrôle encore la 4g 4 puisque
évidemment à venir ça va être le coût de
cet os 6 mais on veut pas le jouer tout
de suite on veut temporiser avant pour
éviter de se faire exploser par la
fameuse attaque qui est restée assise on
avance le pion à eux en premier il y à
gedo g4 est très ennuyeux voilà on
pousse les bouillants et en effet
l'attaqué lecavalier 6 2 de le bousculer
l'idée de ce coût à cette assise c'est
qu'il est très souple qu'on retarde le
développement du cavalier en bébittes ça
on ne l'avait jamais dit certes on veut
garder l'option d'aller soit en 17 soit
en 7 6
vous voyez je prends clé les deux
objectifs le fou s'est vite on le laisse
contrôler jica et donc on retarde cette
poussée de 7 6 à 6,7 un coup souple et
c'est la défense nador la cécilienne
l'âge d'or voilà les blues jouent à f3
alors ça a un double avantage c'est que
ça contrôle savez ça défend 4 et sa
défaite à contrôler la case g4 aussi
pour pouvoir à la fois empêché le
cavalier noir de bimont dire
éventuellement et de jouer g2g quatre
plus tard pour faire une attaque de
pions oui alors effectivement beaucoup
davantage mais un inconvénient majeur
c'est que ça affaiblit la position du
roi blanc si celui ci a envie de faire
le petit rock voilà ta rachadi n'avancer
jamais votre rêve c'est toujours trop
tôt ici le coup f2 f3 évidemment ça
préfigure
le combat c'est à dire que les blancs
vraisemblablement vont essayer de jouer
le fou c'est un an de 3 il ya des petits
problèmes avec le matériel mais ça
s'arrange poussé trois dames d2 et grand
roque est ensuite envoyé les pions avec
g2g 4 et ainsi de suite
mais ici plus trop question pour les
banques de jouer à être le petit rock ça
serait assez douteux là sur f3 laurent
frayssinet réagi avec le coup classique
le coût de 7,5 qui est pratiquement le
seul coup qu'on joue dans cette position
puisque sur aussi à g4s a transpose
enfin karine kasparov
cela dit a gagné énormément de partie
avec ça mais le core i5 et le coût
principal dans cette position et les
trois cas les détroits cavale se replie
normalement donc là bon quand même un
petit bilan choses extrêmement
importantes dans cette position c'est la
casse clé la case centrale des 5
voilà les affaiblit puisque les noirs en
jeu 5 et donc il ya plus petits en qui
peut contrôler cette case pour les noirs
alors qu'en échange effectivement les
noirs contrôler la casse des quatre mais
les blancs pour éventuellement chasse
est une pièce qui s'installerait sur
cette case avec le coup c2 c3 oui
d'autant plus que la caisse des quatre
pour l'instant est quand même très bien
contrôlé par les blancs et donc ses 120
cavaliers la dame a gagné la dame qui
contrôle dans la case des quatre n'est
pas un enjeu dans cette position le gros
le gros souci c'est effectivement cette
case qu'on fait clignoter rouge où la
houle à la voile a pas de pas de cagades
comme on dit donc la classe des 5 c'est
vraiment ça qui est important
1 une des possibilités pour les blancs
c'est éventuellement de chercher à jouer
fou g5 pour s'emparer du contrôle de
cette case là éliminer le défenseur en
tout cas beaucoup de stratégie mais le
plan des blancs principal dans cette
position le plan positionnelle et de
bloquer les noirs sur cette terre des 5
voilà donc qu'on va continuer avec faut
aussi ce tout de suite on commence le
combat
voilà donc là les noirs contre la casse
des cinq donc ils vont vouloir
exactement joué le coup des six des 5
alors peut-être pas tout de suite mais
c'est peut-être dans l'idée à des six
dessins que si on peut jouer c'est bien
ça serait bien ça serait bien ça
libérerait ça libérerait les noirs alors
pour savoir si vous pouvez jouer ce coup
très facile vous comptez le nombre
d'attaquants et nombre de défenseurs ici
en l'occurrence qu'on me dise
d'attaquant il ya le cas wc3 le pion aux
quatre oui la dame d un oui et il ya
combien de défenseurs eric abidal 6 le x
6 et la dame des 8 ça fait donc 3 et 3
donc on peut mettre le pion en d5
puisque s'il est attaqué trois fois il
est défendu trois fois donc des 5
ça peut être jouer effectivement donc on
va voir ce que à jouer joël lautier
il a joué sous trois mois leur faut à 3
qu'a priori on ne pêche pas le coût des
scènes qui n'empêche pas le coût des 5
alors je ne sais pas pourquoi on ne joue
pas le coût des cinq de tête stéphane
alors un élément de réponse est non je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas exactement
non plus mais
en tout cas il ya une forte pression
blanche sur l'ale dame puisqu'il ya
beaucoup de pièces les deux cavaliers le
fou qui mise notamment sur la caisse db6
donc ça peut être un motif d' invasion
mais je ne sais pas ce sera une
réfutation de ceux de ce coût des scènes
qu'elle doit pas forcément être évident
voilà elle n'est pas forcément évidente
je pense qu'effectivement des cinq a
déjà été essayée c'est une certitude
c'est a déjà été joué donc là les
parties de référence sont à trouver
je ne vais pas chercher personnellement
mais c'est envisagé qu'à lever 17 je
sais que c'est le coût principal par
contre il y avait 17 puisque j'ai fait
énormément de parties rapides contres
freyssinet contre laurent frayssinet à
la fin du championnat de france cette
position revenaient systématiquement
quand ils avaient les pièces blanches
donc en voyant cette partie en direct
j'ai vu que laurent était quand même sur
un terrain qu'ils connaissent et très
bien puisqu'ils jouent cette position
avec thé blanc et avec les noirs c'est
donc une de ses spécialités
j'ai quatre voies la bcl on l'a
effectivement l'idée ça va être de choix
chez 5 rien surprise si on joue d'amd ii
et grand roc avant avant g4 les noirs
ont le temps de jouer b5 et cavani b6
loyer et ça et ça change tout puisque
une fois qu'on a réussi à évacuer la
case 17 et bien le cavalier m6 va
pouvoir y aller et ça c'est très très
important
donc je lautier joue le coup j'ai de g4
effectivement c'est une idée
intéressante puisque là les noirs n'ont
pas encore eu le temps de jouer b5 et b6
peut-être il peut nous aurait pu se
caler v6 tout de suite les v6 en bessin
que c'est une catastrophe
dommage parce qu'une catastrophe puisque
ça tu complètement contre je ouais il
faut mettre au jour des cinq donc
laurent frayssinet joue b5 g5 et l'info
s'ils ne le laisse pas respirer donc là
on les blancs il faut le faire
maintenant ce qu'il faut pas donc
laisser ce fameux recueil 17 bouger en b
6 voilà tout à fait voilà cavalerie
s'agisse traque donc on est obligé on va
sur cette case là la perspective ça va
être de revenir en f4 met donc là sur la
case f4 qui est ici mais en fait ce
n'est pas l'idée principale
tout simplement parce que le camion
hashtag bloquent complètement
l'attaquent des blancs n'est ce pas
exactement
exactement donc ici le caillage cas mais
le défenseur avec le pion aux cinq donc
cette case f4 et bien contrôlée
oui on va dire ça quel dessein qu'il
fallait des 5 c'est l'heure d'y aller en
tout cas ce n'était pas une obligation
pour jouer de l'autre il aurait pu jouer
d'amd 2 également il a préféré jouer qui
a aidé saint tout de suite c'est
simplement pour éviter toujours ce coup
qui avait 17 ans b6 qui seraient venus
contrôler une fois de plus la case voilà
là c'est plus possible puisque cavaliers
fou contrôle très bien cette case donc
maintenant bon ce n'est pas une option
pour les noirs de jeu fou prend des cinq
cantons peut reprendre avec les blancs
avec la dame
oui parce que ça laisse le plan des six
faible voilà aussi signé par contre les
blancs étaient obligés si la
configuration était telle que les blancs
pour devrait reprendre du pied ça serait
bon pour le noir puisque ça cache la
faiblesse ça serait bon disons que ça
serait envisageable de donner la paire
de fou on puisqu'on forcerait les blancs
à jouer aux quatre champions des 5 ce
qui serait une bonne opération au niveau
de la structure de pions fawcett donc
l'info hausse est bon à choisir entre
quel fou donné laurent frayssinet
préfère donner son coup de casque noir
c'est vrai qu'après faut prendre des
cinq dames prend des cinqs à sa position
n'aurait pas été très très sympathique
puisqu'il aurait perdu beaucoup de temps
alors que là on voit que comme c'est les
blancs qui viennent jouer kelly prend
fou on reprendre la dame dont on
développe là n'a rien à voir on a
développé notre dame
on n'a pas développé la sienne par
contre on est en enlever un défenseur du
pion des six donc c'est un thème pour
une blanche faire pression son soutien
le plus vite possible
oui on est tout à fait ici c'est le
nouvel enjeu de la position puisque on
sent que les noirs ont quand même du
dynamisme à faire valoir ici il ya la
colonne c'est qui est ouverte donc on
peut très bien envisager de mettre une
tour dessus sur la colonne dans ces huit
le roi blanc a pas trop d'abris sûr dans
cette position puisque petit rock ça
devient très difficile avec le pion au
g5 et grand roque les noirs sont déjà
tout préparé puisqu'ils ont avancé leurs
deux fantassins oui donc ici le gros
problème pour les blancs c'est le roi
mais le gros problème pour les noirs
c'est le clan des six oui parce que le
noir vont au quai du petit côté c'est
sur wii
cavani à 5 voilà cavaliers à 5 donc là
alors ça c'est un coût qui peut faire
pression sur des six puisque une menace
ça peut être cavaliers en baisse est
naturellement qu'elle était venue sur le
casse bessette c'est curieux parce qu'il
va très loin dans le camp ennemi mais a
priori ça a l'air très dangereuse il
avance pour mieux reculer l'ignorance
pour mieux reculer et
côté aussi ce cavalier en cinq six blocs
bien les deux tons noir on peut noter
que ce pilot puis 1 600 ans et est
bloqué alors ça peut jouer aussi un rôle
si les blancs on veut le faire leur
grand retour effectivement ce joueur
différent c'est ça peut jouer un rôle
on envisage aussi quand même qu'avec ses
6 voilà qui chasserait la dame 2e set
sur la casa fuite
oui parce que sinon le pion des six
seraient perdus et en est fier d'elle
serait vraiment très très mal à disons
que c'est sa seule case surtout oui mais
ce serait mal passé non c'est non
seulement ce n'est pas forcément pour
défendre sur des six c'est que c'est la
seule case donc elle sait si c'est une
menace qu'elle a et b 7 en est une autre
laurent frayssinet pendant que des
mesures sérieuses contre tout ça joue
cavalier en c5 libérant des gaz pour la
dame et contrôlant la caisse 17
voilà ils contrôlent la casse bessette
avec lecavalier et avec la dame et avec
la dame qu'est ce g7 doublement
contrôler et en cas de kelis et 6 ont
joué tranquillement
dams et 7 il y aurait pas de problème
ici joël lautier rappel à l'ordre jouent
très logiquement dam des deux idées pas
forcément grand roque puisque le pion à
dos et emprises way le pion le savent où
le fossile peu on pourrait le prendre
mais mais mais peut-être tour d un qui
ferait de pression sur des six oui alors
en tout cas pour l'instant la menace
c'est comme l'europe puisque sur foot
champions à deux il y aurait b2 b3 oui
kimi qui enfermerait le fameux thème
spécifique cher on s'en rappelle 10e 11e
partie du match en soixante douze 72
officier un an c'était la troisième
partie c'était la troisième je ne me
suis pas trompé de beaucoup la troisième
partie du match voilà donc en fait vous
pour 1 2 ou la 12e
on sait que un forfait sur la première
ferme c'est une grosse option il y à b2
b3 et le fou à 2 sera perdue donc en
fait la menace ici c'est de jouer de
rock et ça ça serait très désagréable
puisque dans un seul coup les blancs m
leroy à l'abri attaque le pion des tice
et en même temps se retrouverait avec
toutes les pièces bien placé un transit
que la dame protège le cabinet à saint
lô kahoul
oui elle est quand même très bien passé
stoneham tour s'est vite on s'est vite
donc là ça te pose un petit piège ou au
blanc si les blancs font grand roque
voilà si les blancs font drogue que se
passe-t-il donc six banques font grand
roque
on pourrait le montre le regarde et on
peut le montrer rapidement si les blancs
font grand roque
et ouais faut prendre de fou prend à
deux voies la foux prend 1,2 puisque là
alors l'idée des blancs qui dope qui
serait donc fermé le fou avec b2 b3 et
réfuté tout simplement par cavalier c5
prend b3 ou fois de prendre mon choisy
lembeye marche également avec l'idée
effectivement sur pions prend ou
cavaliers prend on joue cavalier prend
b3 double échec échec par la tour c 8 et
par le cavalier b3 voilà voilà
et on ramasse ensuite évidemment la dame
et la dame est en prise par les
cavaliers donc s'est terminée au
prochain coup faut bouger le roi pour
parer les chèques et le prochain coup la
dame est perdus c'est une espèce de
c'est un échec à la découverte fin c'est
un double échec avec fourchette double
échec avec fourchette donc effectivement
tout simplement la fin de la partie
donc après grand rond-point de on ne
peut pas enfermer le fou donc on a
bêtement perdu 20 pions parce que si on
vient prendre le pion des six en fait
non ça va être simplement un échange de
pions mais c'est pas satisfaisant pour
joël pour joël puisque je crois qu'à une
pointe où il devait y avoir après
d'apprendre et si l'on prend tous
cavaliers detroit tchèque échange franc
et pour le mans une position à peu près
égale à suivre joël lautier n'est pas
satisfait les réfléchi très longtemps
ici je pense qu'il devait réfléchir
entre grand roque celui d'un prend des 6
et le coup qu'il a joué oui il a choisi
un coût beaucoup plus risqué beaucoup
plus tendu le coutour des temps d un
voile alors là si le foot vient de
prendre à deux on peut jouer b2 b3
enfermé le fou donc ce pouvait être hors
jeu et va sûrement un prix très mik s'il
faut prendre à deux je pense qu'on peut
également jouer et d'apprendre les 6 ou
puisque maintenant il y aura plus les
problèmes avec et b3 qu'il y avait avant
voilà sûrement d'abord enfermé le fou je
pense en discret ça a l'air très fort
tout à fait donc lorelei tour bien
l'option des six directement sous la
menace à voilà maintenant l'option des
six effectivement attaqué que vont faire
les noirs pas facile
que vont faire les noirs que va faire
laurent frayssinet il trouve le coup
impressionnant kayak la basse cas très
intéressant parce qu'en fait c'est une
contre attaque
il s'agit d'attaquer le pion b deux mois
que le pied en vedette attaquer donc si
le pion b6 tombe si le pion b2 quittant
mais aussi éventuellement le fiancé 2
puisque la tour
oui les pressions c'est surtout pour ses
deux pieds dans la problématique et on
voit que les blancs du mal parce que si
on joue b2 b3 pour rendre pour attaquer
le cavalier est protégé b2 le coup
cavaliers en c3 attaque la tour d un est
obligé de bouger
et donc du coup mais on perd la pression
sur des six oui il y en a perdu du temps
kelly en c3 qui attaquera la tour d un
la tour d un a pas de case c'est une
catastrophe
ici on ne peut pas jouer b3 l'option b 2
est attaqué on ne peut pas trop prendre
l'option des six puisque le pion ces
deux seraient perdus et d'une façon plus
générale dans cette position les blancs
dont un problème avec leur droit
puisqu'ils ne peuvent plus faire grand
qu'ils vont être obligés de faire le
petit rock donc ce qui soulagerait les
blancs dans cette position c'est des
changes des dames voilà et qu'est-ce
qu'on joue aussi parce que en fait
comment on protège s'était enlevé de
comment on protège ses options mais deux
donc plusieurs possibilités b3 on l'a
éliminée déjà vu ces trois et vingt que
je laissais 3 voilà une autre idée c'est
de jouer c2 c3 qui protège le plan b 2
par la dame et protéger le port louis
par la dame mais il y aurait vous prend
à deux fois semblablement si je me suis
pas trompé vous prend 1,2 à l'air d'un
jour prend 1,2
et donc ici joël lautier trouve quelque
chose de beaucoup plus dynamique et joue
le coup ces deux c'est quand même un peu
surprenant parce qu'en fait cette caste
c4 est quand même bien ou bien on mène
des noirs donc l'idée de jouer n'est pas
évidente le premier amour ici c'est
clairement un sacrifice cette idée c'est
à dire que une fois après le coup de
laurent frayssinet donc qui est chiant
français 4 quelle logique très logique
on voit que toutes les pièces noires se
retrouve en mur et le fou aux six est
bloqué par le mur c4 mais la tour s'est
vite également mon malin et alors que
les bleus gardent tout leur avantage
c'est à dire que mis à part le pion b2
qui est en prise par le cavalier ici
leur concentration de forces sur la
colonne d une efficacité qui restait
intacte evènement il ya que la torah
chiens qui jouent pas puisque les fous
en une action il faut 3 contre une belle
diagonale fief un tap sur ces quatre ya
collaboration qui joue pas alors qu'en
fait chez les noirs on peut estimer que
le père alliage 5 joue pas et la
tourache 8 donc un peu une pièce qui est
un peu en jeu c'est le cas et h5 ici
effectivement faut pas non plus attardé
à ce genre de considération puisque
c'est très tactique
la position a pris un caractère très
dynamique ils les joueurs doivent jouer
vite doivent être très actif pour ne pas
puisque avec quelques coûts de
développement plus les noirs font qu'il
y ait cette partie en voyant la suite
alors à noter quand même pendant qu'on
voit la suite dame b4 donc très joli
coup de geôle authier qui fait pression
justement sur le câble est à 4 je vais
dire que les deux paires valises sont à
la bande
on dit souvent aux échecs faut éviter de
mettre les cavaliers à la mangue mais
parce qu'ils sont pas très actif et là
les deux cas validé noir sans la bande
voyez alors d'ailleurs j'en avais lu la
cavale et blanc aussi le cahier blanc au
site à l'abandon
le cavalier blanc également ils tous les
coalitions à la bande c'est très
géométrique alors maintenant tous les
cavaliers sont sur la même
sur la même hauteur voilà oui c'est
intéressant aussi dit qu'elle et ses
cinq cas les cinq coups très élégant oui
les trois cavaliers sur la même rangée
voilà donc qui est ses cinq doigts pour
laurent croci n'est de toute façon
c'était la seule case donc on va pas
trop commenter ce coup cavaliers profond
séquelles encore récupère le pion et là
par contre pression sur des six
voilà l'énorme pression qu'il prendrait
six c'est trop fort il faut absolument
l'éviter laurent frayssinet joue donc
france et 4 mais ça c'est un groupe
qu'on n'avait pas envie de jouer parce
que non seulement les blancs enfin les
noirs ont donné la paire de foudre en
plus les banques gagnent du temps dans
leur développement en jouant simplement
fou pamfou donc ça semble fou ça
développe le fou avec un gain de temps
de fou contre deux cavaliers avantage de
fou c'est une loi
par contre un peu de répit pour les
noirs donc laurent peuvent profiter pour
ok mais il ya toujours le problème de
ceux qui ont des six arriérés final donc
la combinaison de joël était finement
joué oui la combinaison de joël était
assez bienvenu dans cette position
d'autant plus qu'ici il joue petit rock
est la leur en fera signer à un problème
c'est à dire que le coutil envie de
jouer c'est quand même qu'edf 4 se
fabrique cavaliers à la bande ont essayé
de le réactiver
on va regarder ce coup là cavalier f4
qui semble très très logique
oui voilà ici il y aurait un monde fou
pour un f4 pour le renforcer il faut
prendre une claque qui a 23 24 et
maintenant tour des 5 alors ça ça c'est
un problème puisque là on ne voit pas
comment lors on peut améliorer sa
position maintenant les blancs vont
doubler les tours sur la colonne des
vont jouer b2 b3 ya pas de colonne
ouverte pour les tours de laurent
frayssinet le cav l option des six
toujours sous pression et le point 4
aussi est faible et le plus marqué est
et faible hier que la dame va venir se
replacer en d2 attaqué le pion à quatre
attaques et puis un cap et le pion des
six et puis on décide bon mais ça l'idée
déjà sous grosse pression donc ici c'est
un grave problème pour laurent puisque
après donc petit rock des blancs il ne
peut pas jouer cavalier 4 ça c'est grave
donc il faut trouver un plan a et vous
trouvez un plan alors il a il a noté que
le pion g5 est bien avancée et donc
pourrait faire l'objet de
tentative des changes pour activer ces
tout dans le coup et sept et six de
toute façon il n'a pas le choix ici il
faut qu'ils attaquent le roi blanc qui
est affaibli dans cette position voilà
donc dont crois je suis tu auras je suis
dit obligé puisque le fou c4 on peut
noter empêcher le coup et on peut y
avait remarqué quand même il y avait un
clouage voyage vient clouer un f6
étaient interdits à cause du fou c4 donc
là l'idée de des noirs c'est bien de
jouer
f 7 6 où est ce steve 5 voilà pour
essayer d'augmenter une contre attaque
contre l'euro blanc qui finalement peut
s'avérer dangereux à ce qu'on attaque
puisque laurent blanc il mal défendu le
rôle on a mal défendu et surtout le
l'atout principal des noirs dans cette
position c'est le cavaly kasparov ou le
cavalier etienne bacrot on peut appeler
comme on veut quand il vient se placer
en f4 il devient très très fort que
l'été bat qu il devient très très fort
puisque c'est une pièce d'attac qui est
vraiment énorme qui est gigantesque qui
rayonne sur tout tout le côté rock du
roi donc ici le cas les 1/4 est un
élément d'attac déterminant et laurent
frayssinet à la perspective de jouer
cavalier ses 56 et ensuite donc d'avoir
un duo de cavalli qui arriverait sur
cette case donc ça serait bien parce
qu'un cavalier en f4 ça serait très fort
ici évidemment il veut ouvrir d'abord le
il veut enlever se plonger 5 pour
pouvoir passer la dame passer les tours
ensuite m lequel 24 il un plan d'attaqué
ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'en
contrepartie les blancs d'oeuf ou et de
l'autre côté la bataille est
complètement perdue puisque il ya 200
contre 1 nos clients vont faire actions
passées et vont l'envoyer à dame voilà
la baptisa une question de rapidité
voilà la bataille si si il aura tant
trop la finale et permit enfin en tout
cas elle est mal engagée à la finale et
sans espoir sans même des deux dames des
deux fait pression sur des six au
passage attaque décision est une menace
d'un point des six tours cd vite il faut
pas se tromper tour alors ils gardent
l'auto puisqu'il veut comme il veut
ouvrir cette fameuse colonne des fonds à
divo joué à vii et si ce gars est tour
pour pouvoir près qu'elle s'active un
wiki stores ne se trompe pas de tours
voilà rouach un an rachat donc je joue
elle aussi mais s'en vont à l'abri
cavaliers aux six attaques le pion chez
cinq noms ne l'attaquent pas d'ailleurs
exercice venir au f4 moi l'avenir afin
puisque le projet 5 est bien protégé par
le fouet 3 et par l'anam oui donc ici
pas de problème joël lautier on lui dit
pas de foi qui n'est plus en prise ouais
c
avec joël ses traits le calcul est très
brutal très simple donc là je ne savent
dire que laurent a quand même sacré film
fut un jour lui aussi ce we will laurent
de 28 ans et donne surtout en fait toute
la partie statique de cette position
c'est dire que la maintenant simplement
s'il ne marque pas joël lautier dans
cette position ben quoi il l'appliqué
abandonné puisque d'options plus la
paire de fou ça avance comme des béliers
moyen de glisse ici effectivement on
dirait un doublé chez d'avancé y'a pas
de problème il faut aller mater qualité
h f k alors ça c'est très intéressant
puisqu'une pions g5 est en prise oui oui
ça me prendrait 5 elle peut être joué
puisque le fou ne compteront plus je le
tiens ne défend pas de toute façon
c'était très difficile de défendre se
plonger 5 on pouvait le défendre avec
tours gênant mais ça posait des
problèmes puisque après l'option f3 elle
et se retrouver en crise
voilà donc faussée cadre d'un projet ça
y est donc qui récupère son pion
finalement avec il a qu'a réussi à avoir
un peu parce qu'ils voulaient contre le
contrôle à la perte de ce fameux pion à
six qui commet un péché un peu les
petits ont bien avancé
ils obtiennent petites attaques contre
le roi blanc une petite jenny parce
qu'en fait on va voir que c'est
difficile d'être d'attaqué contre une
position comme ça où les deux fous
peuvent à la fois défendre et protéger
les pions qui avance il ya un autre
atout pour la défense dans cette
position c'est que effectivement il ya
toutes les défenses latéral on voit la
dame ici qui contrôlent beaucoup de
caves on peut mettre une tour sur la
colonne g et le contrôlera également
beaucoup de cases donc les bleus ont des
facilités pour contrôler des cases dans
leur camp et pour l'instant les noirs
attaque quand même 100 tours c'est à
dire que les deux tours noirs sont
complètement hors de l'eau or de
l'attaquant d'éviter les fuites donc ici
il va falloir réorganiser tout ça à 4
les blancs eux c'est très clair dans
leur tête ils font ce faux crédits
version dont les blancs et donc ce pion
il faut qu'il aille en a 7 pour menacer
le faire d'un an à 8
voilà son nom qui plus il avancera plus
les blancs aux rencontres contre eux je
le côté évidence il laisse trop le nord
attaqué ils vont finir par avoir de gros
problèmes
oui là c'est c'est à quitte ou double ça
passe ou ça casse laurent frayssinet
joue un peu son va tout c'est en donnant
le pion à 6 il a vraiment essayé tout ce
qu'ils pouvaient ici il peut
malheureusement pas jouer f5 dans cette
position puisque reffouh prend qu'avec
de six mois là faut prendre car il y
aussi c'est le carrier f4 ne peut pas
reprendre puisque la dame serait perdu 1
comme sur l'impact du fou 3 donc ces
opérations d'inventaire d'alger 600
films et ses 5 ou 2 c'est dommage un
coup il perd du temps hyper du temps
mais c'est pas grave puisque il ya quand
même des belles perspectives d'attac f5
f5 menace pions que quatre jeux le thé
défend je m'en fous des seins alors
double intérêt encore une fois ce que
disait d'ailleurs les fous peuvent à la
fois défendre et attaquer donc se fout
des cinq control4 donc défendre un cadre
très bien et en plus ils contrôlent la
case à huit la classe de promotion du
pian ce qui fait qu'il a un double effet
j'allais dire il ya la double effet en
tout cas il a un effet complètement
double elle prend le 4 fou prend aux
quatre attaques
la dame g6 oui et contrôle toujours la
case habite
oui donc ça c'est très bien fou prend
1,4 d'un match 5
damages saigne et l'or maintenant les
noirs ont fait une menace ils ont une
menace très forte pour cette édition oui
une menace très forte alors que je vois
plus parce que j'ai dû la voir monsieur
là je les vois plus d'accord et bien
c'était le coup d essai le fameux coup
libérateur de la sicilienne qui arrive
toujours quand on ne l'attend plus loin
puisque le food et plus ont des saints
chrétiens ne sont pas bloqués ils sont
libres d'avancé donc la menace est ou
était 5 qui va chasser le fougueux 4 qui
va donc empêché et son autre et va
rendre la mobilité aux points centraux
oui puisque après on va jouer des femmes
des quatre des cadres et en l'air le
deuxième fois 62e fou en pêcheur les
noirs de repousser a6 a7 puisqu'on va
contrôler la casa 7 alors que pour
l'instant le faux 3 le contrôle bien
donc c'est une grosse menace des noirs
énorme menace qui est parée par joël
lautier fou b6 contre attaque sur la
tour il faut donc la bouger en fait
n'aurait pu sacrifier la qualité s'il ne
sera envisagée ça oui oui c'est toujours
possible de s'arrêter et jouer des six
des cinq pour donner la tour c'est une
possibilité on peut citer que tout n'est
pas forcément elle aurait pu choisir ce
oui mais ici quand même ils menacent
encore des six des cinq dans cette
position c'est beaucoup plus logique
s'ils jouent parce que ils traquent pas
tout de suite il donne pas tout de suite
tout le du matériel
oui après tout ces six il replace encore
la tour sur le colonel orcel de ses
forces peut plus jouer des cinq noms
mais il un autre plan ici donc je le
notais joue pas six la logique est
maintenant qu'avec des cadres alors
c'est là que ça devient
c'est là que ça devient compliqué c'est
là que ça devient fou et que laurent
frayssinet à essayer de prendre le
maximum de ses chances impliqués des
cadres donc c'est un coup très fort
puisque ces attaques le fou c6 les deux
fous étaient trop forts il faut des 6 et
6 il utilisait les soutenir le plus ou
moins jusqu'à dame
oui donc il fallait en éliminer un ici
qui a aidé quatre ces attaques le fossé
6 donc ça gagne du temps si le fou vient
à bouger ce qui est une possibilité il
ya le plus bref trois quêtes emprise
enfin qui peut l'être qui peut l'être si
le fougueux respect selon eux des
banales en fait le fou a tout simplement
très peu de casse dans cette position
sylvian bessette on notera plus de
pousser le pion à bref problème pour
joël lautier qui joue faut planquer 4
donc ça libère un peu de pression tu
comprends ouais maintenant le pion à ne
peut pas avancer puisque la tour f 7
fait de défense latérale
voilà il ya plus le fou pour contrôler
et donc le coût logique de reprendre
donne l'option permet de contrôler la
cadence est aussi d'en prendre quatre
mais ici ça perd le contrôle de la 4g 2
donc ça permet à laurent frayssinet de
menacer vos maths éventuellement voilà
dame gsm menace de maths
benoît la première menacée dans l'art ça
y est ça y est c'est en train de se
désarmer peut encore imaginer qu noir
peuvent avoir une attaque gagnante c'est
encore possible
on peut l'imaginer bien sûr d'alger 1
dames g1 et la voilà là c'est une
manoeuvre assez sympathique
ouais bon j'ai trouvé ça assez amusant
de voir cette manoeuvre puisque la dame
c'est une pièce d'attac très forte au
parlement on la laisse à l'attack et là
laurent frayssinet va servir de saddam
pour aller faire une diversion
étrange il va il va repasser de l'autre
côté en fait il va jouer damas cinq donc
dans la seine attaque le pion à la
taxation à 6 voilà donc réponse de
l'authie être naturel tours 1 alors
peut-être alors ça c'est typique on dit
souvent quand un canton à un pion passé
l'idéal c'est de mettre une tour
derrière pour l'aider a poussé puisque
la tour de contrôle de loin le pouce le
pouce le pouce ils valaient jusqu'à nam
malheureusement un jeune dame à cinq là
laurent frayssinet finalement donne des
temps au blanc pour jouer ce coup c'est
vrai mais la tour saint était bien placé
puisque maintenant on en profite encore
une fois on vous donne c'est cette
attaque le fossé 6 donc ça c'est bien
pour moi aussi mc cette fouille b727 le
faut bien se mettre sur une mauvaise
case alors à noter quand même la
position précédente que sur tours c1 on
ne refait une fourchette pour ses seins
il y aurait des quatre prévenus eux deux
les deux attaques la dame la dame et la
tour siens et la tour cn donc ici
problème pour jouer de lautier puisque
une fois de plus il revient sur la case
aux quatre lots qui ont des s'inquiète
enfin l'option des six peu avancé en d5
très important oui donc le foot doit
venir en b cet élan menace pas à cette
encore puisque la table prend fou mais
madame prend fou exactement donc c'est
un problème et laurent frayssinet en
profitent ils jouent des six des 5 lui
aussi un pion passé et qu'on donne là
dessus un double intérêt c'est que sa
bouche aussi le fou ça éventuellement ça
crée une menace noir qui est d'avancer
le pion central puisque c'est quand même
bien passé aussi pour les noirs et aussi
ça libère la déconnade de la dame qui
tape sur age 2 donc ça peut jouer un
rôle fait cette intrigue triple intérêt
triple intérêt
t'auras trois tours et si ce seuil est
maintenant on passe les tours l'effet
retour donc qui n'était pas sur les
colonnes les tournus colonies voilà les
appels ouais tour c'est un donc d'atos
et en attaque la dame peut faire
attention
ah oui donc dans le death est très
important puisqu'il faut garder le
contact avec le fou puisque sinon on
joue à 6 à 7 et dames qui suit 1 ouais
là on a clairement une lutte contre eux
qui ont passé les joueurs sont oreilles
notent ils ont joué vite
d'ailleurs nous aussi on joue vite
puisqu'on est également aux heynckes
d'alger quatre dames b5
on garde toujours le contact avec le fou
et la 40e coup dernier coup je vais
lautier doit jouer il est pressé par le
temps ou alors interné qu on en rappel
avant le contrôle de temps c'est dire
qu'au delà
une fois qu'il aura joué son 40e ou une
fois que chacun des deux joueurs ont
joué la carte et beaucoup ont valeur
ajoutée 50 minutes supplémentaires donc
ici je le dis et stressé il n'a plus que
quelques minutes quelques secondes même
pour jouer son dernier coup et jouent le
coup à 6 à 7 quand même combinaison
quand même puisque le fou bessette est
en prise et la tour f 8 et la dame 17
contrôleront bien la casa 8 donc a
priori ça a l'air d'être en manque ou
première possibilité
laurent frayssinet également été stressé
par le temps il joue d'un premier set
voilà ça c'est une c'est une variante
qui s'envisage essayons de voir ça donc
là il ya à cette a8 a7 a8 peu d'âme dame
donc il faut prendre on prend aussi up
la dame de prendre d'emprunt tour et là
le fameux match du couloir tour ses huit
échecs autant ces huit échecs s'est
finie sur dame prend tour il y as d'un
programme et mat
ouais et surtout réduite on va prendre
la dame mais ensuite on ramasse le
cavalier voilà donc c'est donc fini
c'est donc fini gros avantage blanc donc
ici après à 7
donc c'est une combinaison folle et noir
pas prendre le fou à cause du vin du
couloir donc laurent de fasciner trouve
l'astuce alors la première chose qu'on
se dit c'est quand même c'est foutu oui
c'est foutu là il est cuit puisqu'on
peut vraiment pas évité à 7 à 8
on ne peut pas menacer l'at on ne peut
rien faire et pourtant laurent
frayssinous un coup ils jouent h7
achetant un coup qu'on appelle
intermédiaire intermédiaire en contre
attaque la dame et on libère la case h7
pour le roi donc on va pouvoir prendre
le fou voilà laissa ensuite dans ses
demandes et d'ailleurs le parti est ce
que je veux le dire est vivant il avait
sûrement de vue alors moi je ne pense
qu'il ne l'ait pas vu le même tube oh
ouais je pense que c'est possible aussi
simple que ça lui échapper ce coup h 7 h
en tout cas je ne pense pas qu'il ait
calculé avec précision toutes les
conséquences du coup à 7 ou alors il
s'est dit le coût s est efforcé de toute
façon je suis obligé de le jouer mais là
il ya des variantes extrêmement
compliqué alors je le fais je voulais
seul coup à partir de maintenant les
deux joueurs jouent les seuls coups
pendant une longue séquence d'alger un
danger alors pourquoi seule course à
contrôler à 7 mais bon c'est pas ça
contre l'a7 et on va voir que c'est très
très important ça contrôle à cet effet
la controverse est alors moins d'un
profond 17 maintenant de toute façon ça
c'était imparable alors à noter on va on
va marquer ça que dame j'ai un contrôle
la casa 7 vallons va bien le noter parce
que c'est très important en figurant
pour la suite de la de la partie voilà
et ce après un contrôle aussi la case g7
oui alors ça effectivement ça c'est
important également puisque ça fait
surgir des idées voilà ici je veux loti
fait d'am dam
voilà donc le rang freyssinet prend
prend hélas hélas alors là c'est là que
la magie commence on commence par jouer
des tours c7 mettant la tour emprise ou
un tourin prise mais alors par contre
j'ai tout repris mais il faut noter que
j'attaque la dame donc la dame est
attaqué et je menace dame prendrait cet
échec et mat
donc on n'a pas trop le choix nous
sommes allés en prise mais il faut le
reprendre donc on a l'impression que les
blancs
des bâtons pour se faire taper dessus
mais mes draps l'entouré chez voilà tu
empruntes tour échec on récupère l'autre
tour roanne est forcée et maintenant
voilà l'idée de variété dans un même
thème voilà tour à sept tours à ces
attaques la dame et c'est même une
enfilade en fait tout simplement
ben oui puisque la le pion g7 se
retrouvent enfin voila si la dame
bougies adam pranger 7 matches 7 et
derrière derrière tout ça et on peut
l'holocauste aurait été idéal serait de
jouer dame eux 5 qui contrôle de sept en
tout temps par an mais malheureusement
la tour et fils l'empêchent la dame de
protéger donc 2005 ne contrôle pas g7
ici laurent frayssinet père la dame mais
ce n'est pas grave puisqu'il a des
pièces très bien placé d'apprendre d'un
prompt et là je crois que c'est la gaffe
à mon avis ici je n'ai pas compris
pourquoi laurent frayssinet n'a pas joué
le coup h 5 h 4 alors il ya sans doute
une explication mais je ne les ai pas
trouvés pourquoi je 5h 4h 5h 4 5 ou 10
ans positionnelle c'est pour empêcher
les banques de jouer eux mêmes h cartes
comme ce qui s'est passé dans la partie
on va on va aller le regarde et après
mais ici c'est bien parce que avec le
pion aux 4 on a des perspectives on va
progresser de jouer g7 g5 et on va faire
une sorte de cage le blocus d'une sorte
de cache pour le roi blanc oui puisque
le cavalier en f4 contrôler la case h3
la 4g 2 et le pion aux quatre maintenant
contrôler laquelle j'ai 3 donc on
contrôle trois cases imaginons qu'on
arrive à passer la tour en ces six
séances et deux on va contrôler
énormément de gaz autour du roi
donc on va pouvoir faire beaucoup
d'échecs étant éventuellement faire un
échec perpétuel ou en tout cas avec des
menaces fortes qui vont peut-être
permettre au noir de prendre le pion b2
par exemple ici sur qui on saute il ya
une grande chance deux nuls
c'était même avantage noir si on profite
donc ici il aurait dû jouer ça à la
place de quoi laurent frayssinet de
tours otis un peu précipitamment puisque
maintenant c'est les blancs qui joue h 2
h 4 à noter que le tourisme onat et matt
encore une fois si ce n'est à ses maths
mais là ça change tout pourquoi parce
que le cavadee f4 maintenant est
complètement instable
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut plus jouer le
coup g7 g5 voilà on peut plus protéger
définitivement ce cavalier il sera tôt
ou tard mis en situation ne porte à faux
et donc le gros problème effectivement
quand on a un cavalier et qu'on sait pas
où le mettre
et bien c'est qu'on se fait
simplement pousser nos pièces hors des
bonnes cases et là c'est une catastrophe
le camion f4 si on avait pu le garder
ça aurait été une très bonne opération
là on va voir en quelques coups qu'on ne
peut pas laurent frayssinet au tour aux
deux jeux lautier attaque le cavaliere
qu'adam des quatre îles etc attaque ne
peux pas le défendre
calé j'ai 6 mai g6 et là je vais
l'hautil pousse son pion passé
brillamment de diversion va falloir
l'arrêté est là qu est ce qu on peut
faire le cavalier angers 6 cd très mal
placé ouais c'est clair la tour ne peut
pas revenir sur la caisse b2 puisque la
dame notre contrôle donc tout simplement
ici ça va être très dur d'arrêter ce
pion c'est très très délicat
laurent frayssinet lukebadio 5 et après
demain prend des cinq îles à vendre
il abandonne puisque le cavalier ne sait
toujours pas où aller et l'option b va
avancer
youtube est assez sévère a redonné au
moins deux cavaliers pour la pièce et
après la dame gagne facilement contre la
toux très jolie partie donc peut-être a
résumé la partie puisqu'elle est quand
même assez grande elle comporte beaucoup
de phases
ouais phase de l'ouverture le combat
pour la casse des cinq donc plus ou
moins gagné par joël lautier puisqu'elle
a réussi à prendre l'aventage de la
paire de fou dans cette phase-là ans
suite à des complications tactique
laurent frayssinet joue son va tout pour
aller attaquer le roi john le tien la
donne la peur de faux parfums donne la
paire de fou il avait déjà deux ils
avaient déjà déjà commencé par une
fausse est donc ensuite il donne le pion
à 6 pour essayer d'avoir de la taxe sur
le roi il a de la tacc il a de la tacc
de façon spectaculaire
voilà mais peut-être il rate son coup
fameux coup h4 que terre et l'a donc une
fois que la position est sortie de la
phase complètement folle tactique et
bien laurent frayssinet au 46e ou fait
une faute il ne joue pas le coût atteint
15,4 hilton au blanc l'occasion de le
jouer il n'arrive pas à stabiliser ces
pièces est donc finalement la dame
l'emportent sur tout et cavaliers donc
c'était peut-être chaud pour les noirs
en tout cas très jolie partie des deux
joueurs on peut dire que le niveau de
cette partie est très très fort contre
et relever le niveau des joueurs
français s'est amélioré mais c'est ce
qu'on va voir peut-être dans les news
notre prochaine séquence puisqu'on a des
français qualifiés aux championnats du
monde et on a une liste complète
voilà donc tout de suite les news
de la semaine
voilà donc des news avec
on va parler donc 2e
premier première chose c'est robert
fontaine alors robert fontaine la star
la star en ce moment il est tout lui
réussit alors il fait un tournoi
actuellement en angleterre qui s'appelle
le golombek mémorial tournament
oui alors robert n'était pas qualifiée
pour le zonal puisqu'ils n'étaient pas
dans les six premiers au championnat de
france mais dont qu'il fait ce tournoi
sur invitation faut rappeler que robert
et c'est un tout jeune joueur il ya un
peu premiers âges de bach rouge queen
d'avoir 17 ans non non il apporte en
même temps paru il ya un peu plus âgés
alors il est maître international
il a terminé dans la combe as du
championnat de france et il fait donc là
un tournoi de grand maître ou pour
l'instant ils cartonnent fort oui
effectivement alors il a fait une norme
de grands maîtres en 97 il est à la
recherche de normes supplémentaires pour
acquérir le titre de grand maître
il était très déçu de sa participation
nationale vous pouvez le revoir
évidemment toujours dans les archives
très simplement et ici il a quatre
points sur cinq actuellement dans un
tournoi de grand maître extrêmement fort
quel point sur cinq et il lui reste donc
4 4 parties à jouer il faut qu'il fasse
deux points sur quatre pour faire la
norme
il va jouer avec les noirs contre
matthew turner qui est un des plus
faibles de ce tournoi tout simplement
oui ensuite il aura les blancs contre
john holmes les noirs contre ebden ça
c'est difficile puisque c'est le fameux
boucher anglais et ensuite à la dernière
ronde il pourra même s'il a déjà perdu
une partie joué son va tout contre eux
par qu'elles ont et qui fait un tournoi
de cauchemar puisqu'il n'a pas encore
gagné deux parties donc les derniers et
dernier ex-aequo d'ailleurs voilà un
ex-aequo donc très bon très bon tournoi
de robert fontaine
c'est rare de voir un français à
l'antenne à se tourner en anglais oui
c'est à peine tonnes alors je ne sais
pas où est cette ville mais c'est le
fameux mémorial golombek du nom du
célèbre mécène un anglais qui a légué
toute sa fortune pour qu'on organise des
tournées à l'échec
voilà donc robert centaines dans ce
tournoi très fort en anglais donc toi
grand maître dans lequel il va sûrement
réussir ça alors il a déjà fait
d'énormes rohmer sûrement robert a fait
une norme en 97
au moment où il a
il a eu son titre de maître il avait
commencé en faisant une norme de grands
maîtres ce qui était très impressionnant
malheureusement il n'a pas confirmé
depuis mais peut-être trois ans après
une nouvelle norme alors en tout cas
c'est pas tout dans les derniers
information puisque on en parlera
peut-être un peu plus la semaine
prochaine
c'est malheureux que ce soit en même
temps que le zonage un peu on peut dire
ça quand même
c'est la coupe du monde des échecs
organisé par la fidh et en chine cette
année atteignant donc on avait fait un
spécial signe d'ailleurs cette année
voyez l'année dernière en septembre
autant je sais plus donc où tu étais
allé en chine avec arnaud hauchard oui
et donc se coupe du monde donc il ya eu
à shenyang en chine retrouve regroupe
des joueurs parmi les meilleurs du monde
il ya un homme qui est là donc numéro
trois mondial ni chronique b kasparov ne
sont évidemment puisqu'ils préparent
leur match qui aura lieu à londres mais
tous les autres sont là on peut
retrouver des rosés vite on peut
retrouver aussi à créer votre shopping
en dessous des hortes vide l'air kiev
qui est également galles fonde toute une
panoplie de très bons joueurs
voilà est par contre d annoter des
chinois mais chinois dong soo hyun c'est
en chine et ye yang tuan oui ils sont
très connus nismo quand même très connue
des yanks un des premiers joueurs
chinois avoir franchi la barre des 2600
points elo c'est effectivement il est
assez âgée doit avoir une quarantaine la
grande quarantaine d'années passées il
joue extrêmement bien joué extrêmement
bien moins de deux mille six cent
soixante dix il est donc très très bien
placé au niveau mondial et mettre en
premier un peuple lui s'éteint c'est un
très très bon joueur se dit logement est
alors donc qu'est ce qui se passe dans
cette coupe du monde
alors qu'est ce qui se passe se coupe du
monde donc il y avait des groupes de
qualification quatre groupes de
qualification les deux premiers étaient
qualifiés pour les quarts de finale ça
ressemble beaucoup à la coupe du monde
de foot
sauf que le groupe était composé de six
joueurs au lieu de quatre comme pour le
foot alors à noter donc quatre groupes a
b c d alors groupe à se sont qualifiés
hormis l'os
gilberto milieu brésilien faisait b
peut-être c'est un de ses meilleurs
résultats
parce que s'il n'est pas bien quand même
très bien il y avait notamment battu
shirov au fameux tournoi merida au
mexique
oui c'est vrai les nains figurer là bas
ils se qualifient régulièrement pour le
championnat du monde puisqu'il avait
déjà joué l'année dernière
belov c'est un des meilleurs joueurs
brésiliens depuis assez longtemps déjà
alors à noter dans ce groupe à la grosse
surprise c'est morose et vicenza rosé
beach numéro quatre mondial actuel qui
prend trois bulles d'encre éliminé
éliminer complètement donc directement
lié mauvaise forme petite forme pour
alexander morozevich donc un deuxième
qualifié je crois que c'était la zone
par julie voilà smaïl paraissent vidic
qui s'est qualifié avec 3 points donc
tout seul détaché aussi heureusement il
parait il il faut rappeler que c'est
l'entraîneur des viennes macro wild
etienne bacrot et il me semble de garry
kasparov
oui il a dû l'être a confirmé mais en
tout cas c'est l'entraîneur par
excellence et un est un joueur
extrêmement forts notamment partie
rapide et il s'est qualifié en partie
rapide si je me trompe bryant s'est
qualifié au départage non non non pardon
il s'est qualifié tout seul il s'est
qualifié il s'est qualifié tout seul il
y avait 2000 points d'avancé alors à
savoir effectivement les joueurs égalité
jouer des partages alors dans le groupe
b on retrouve qualifié bx wenchuan c'est
un peu la surprise en tête de ce groupe
un outil qui avait péno mario dans ce
groupe qui prend de bulles un net est
donc entre short et ivantchouk qui avait
trois points ça s'est joué au départage
justement et c'est yves en dessous qui
là qu'il a remporté donc le départage
sont en semi rapide voilà donc yves hand
foot on retrouve donc les ont peut dire
que les meilleurs quand même se qualifie
c'est sa part donc la surprise c'est une
heureuse éviteront peut pas dire que
pendant variance est une surprise parce
qu'il est très fort mais il est encore
que junior le pauvre donc il faut qu'ils
apprennent un peu on va aller vite
puisqu'il va nous rester très peu de
temps dans le groupe c
marief s'est qualifié avec donc c'est
chez plus il sévit de l'air on vous
spécial qui s'est qualifié je crois que
sebastian ces mots spéciale donc a dû se
qualifier au départage et enfin groupe d
alors à nantes sans surprise
tranquillement devant un homme facile
voilà est devant
quatre chefs et guelph en alors mathieu
donc notre russo français voient les
premiers de la liste france qui était
présent au grand prix de bordeaux on
peut le rappeler qui fait qui fait une
très belle année a fait des bons
résultats en matches mais
malheureusement là il chutait alors une
fois de plus ce galeux fondre à une fois
de plus c'est c'est vraiment sa bête
noire boris quelle forme puisque en
championnat du monde je crois qu'il a
déjà éliminé deux fois oui si je me
trompe pas de quatre chefs s'est fait
sortir deux fois par maurice galle fonde
alors par contre qu'à moitié à chaque
fois au match des partages voit la marge
du partage ils ont fait deux parties
nulles en semi rapides et anglet c'est
la spécialité de quatre chefs mais il a
chuté
oui enfin c'est la spécialité de galles
font aussi il faut relativiser tous ces
joueurs sont extrêmement forts donc
donc voilà donc les qualifie qu'il ait
qualifié ces joueurs là donc il y en a
il y en a huit voix l'arrière
s'affrontant système coupe
voilà ce système coûte donc deux matches
et après les départage alors il y avait
des il y avait des égalités surtout les
trois matches et ce aux fins ou à nantes
a battu ivan doux nom de pulvériser
voilà donc éteinte en finale
et puis on les autres matches on a pas
on n'a pas réussi à avoir les résultats
on les aura évidemment pour la semaine
prochaine
alors c'est dommage encore une fois on
peut citer que ceux cette superbe coupe
du monde ait lieu en même temps que le
zonage
enfin le zonal c'est quand même de
l'actualité principalement françaises
oui mais puisque comme on va le voir
d'ailleurs maintenant le zona le
qualifie pour le championnat du monde
voilà et la liste des très qualifiés
vient d'être rendue donc on voit pour ça
il ya différents différents facteurs de
qualification donc bien combien de fric
et de pré qualifiés il y en a cent 100
il y aura sans qualifier en tout oui en
tout qui sont requis sont qualifiés
comme ça il y en a quatre qui sont pris
de l'année dernière les quatre demi
finalistes
oui donc qualif man akopian des six
pianos adams ce qui avait bien marché
l'année dernière par le vélo y en a
trente ans les 30 par le mail ou
d'accords 30 par le vélo quatre juniors
donc bien du nord les quatre meilleurs
juniors ce qui explique que bacrot est
qualifié voilà en fait on prend les
juniors à plus de 2600 points elo moi il
y en a quatre dans le monde il ya bono
marguelov
évidemment les meilleurs bacrot malakoff
et gris tchouk que tout malakoff à
greccio qu'on avait vu
au tournoi de vienne je crois qu'on a
quelques images choc et j'ai obtenu mon
shoot champion du monde junior en un
champion du monde 99 voilà la championne
du monde féminin oxygène ensuite il ya
des nominés par le président et c'est là
qu'on a une surprise on a notre star
française national boris spassky oui la
star du grand prix du sénat oui et
championne du monde 72 69 pardon 69
donc ça fait 6 milliards ils avaient dit
qu'ils joueraient plus trop mais en fait
il continue à jouer comme ça on lui
demande le dernier qualifié par le vélo
c'est bhl à 17 4 chefs ont également
france est donc en fait finalement voilà
éliminé en coupe du monde mais qualifiée
pour chaque plat du monde sinon je crois
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre surprise tous
les autres joueurs sont qualifiés par
les taux nationaux et donc on n'attend
plus que la zone 1.1 pour que les
joueurs puissent commencer à se préparer
pour le championnat du monde qui aura
lieu à new delhi était en mieux des
idées le terrain à partir du mois de
novembre puisque jusqu'en décembre
donc on peut noter qu'on aura droit
cette année donc à deux championnats du
monde kasparov kramnik championnat du
monde officieux
à l'ancienne manière à la manière de
steinitz un peu et puis et puis le
champion du monde fis des en match
d'élimination qu'il fait ou ce qui n'est
pas aussi qui réunit pas tous les
suffrages non plus etc a le mérite
d'exister mais voilà on est plus on
n'est plus dans l'image de candidats etc
à noter quand même 3 millions de dollars
de prix sans les rites ça mérite d'être
dit 3100 joueurs 3 millions de dollars
de prix évidemment dans le trait sur un
blog sans fatigue en a l'occasion d'y
revenir longuement voilà donc on vous
donne rendez vous dès la semaine
prochaine pour la suite des événements
est chaud
oui